look guys one minute I'm a quirky girl
that Shops at Zara and the next minute
I'm Santa /local perv number one hey job
grace you thought too hard about this
now hair goes in the front to show you
all the hard work I've put into making
it look clean happy holidays guys I
don't listen to Christmas music I just
listen to the sound of crime
almost as heart-wrenching as that two
front teeth some look at this festive
decor you're welcome
I went on my tumblr Nash you guys what
kind of video did you want to see today
and someone said they wanted to see a
video of how about Christmas with your
family this video might be happening a
little late for you you might already be
with your family but hey I've said
before I'll say it again I like my video
ideas unlike I like my periods late hey
oh girl making a joke about period it's
really progressive helping the cause a
lot of you will be around family and or
people that make you uncomfortable over
this holiday season here are my
last-minute quick tips on how to handle
any and all of those situations number
one if you're going home for the
holidays and you're staying for a period
of time treat your house like the game
of Risk claim a territory and protect it
you're gonna want a private comfortable
place that you can go to and look up
whisper videos I don't know what the few
kids into it that I don't know I don't
know unlike that old guy that's not
allowed around that elementary school
anymore I'm out of touch not in touch I
don't touch what Wow you want to claim a
spot a spot that can be yours over
whatever duration of time you'll be
spending in said house or place I don't
know were you raised in an open field
are you a cow that has learned how to
use YouTube if so that is utterly
amazing god this is going great those of
you that are not familiar with the game
of Risk Justice I used to play the game
of Risk with my brothers growing up and
it got heated so he
to the point that my younger brother
came almost tried to induce vomiting on
the game board to make the gameplay
style because I wasn't going as he
wanted it to we had a nickname for Tim
with on him North Korea camp giacomo
right number two like a paid off witness
in a courtroom have prepared answers you
are probably going to interact with a
family member or friend and/or animal
they gained the ability to speak and
they're gonna ask you questions now we
all hate they've all heard a million
times anticipate this and have some
answers here are some examples have you
found a job have you found a job that
isn't interrogating my life I like your
brooch so deep a boyfriend or girlfriend
or fetish oh my god scandal right oh my
god I love scandal oh my god okay
season one great you talk about scandal
at me and I'm just gonna scoop spoonfuls
of this light ranch vegetable dip into
and around my mouth do you have any
future plans you know I do have a couple
options I'm kind of in-between
unexpected pregnancy and or unexpected
drug addiction but no matter what I I
think I'll always have a through-line of
struggling to deal with my anxiety and
depression also I'd love to learn
Photoshop more that light ranch dip
right number three like a holiday gift
be present being home is really special
so make sure that while you're there you
at least spend some time logging off and
disconnecting from the
and be present with your family or
friends but make sure that you Instagram
it and tweet about how much you love
hanging out presently with your family
and friends tumblr big blog posts about
how the end of the year you get so
sentimental about being home around your
family and friends privacy of your
Kamchatka and snapchat at number four it
is common to feel extremely bored around
your family so I encourage you to make
up games here are some examples try
coming up with other words for yes and
no instead of an ugly sweater party play
the sensible sweater party where you
just kind of judge all of the sensible
sweaters their aunts and uncles will
inevitably be wearing at your holiday
parties and then very dramatically and
audibly choose a winner and loser
hashtag de sipan a not sponsored see how
many family members you can get to
accidentally say the phrase dirty taint
try to get one of your uncle's to get
their belly button pierced a lot of
people get together and they bake
cookies or they make ornaments for trees
I say get all your family together you
make toe rings a tacky family is it a
lot of people try and use mistletoe is a
fun awkward way to get people to kiss
each other here's my idea instead of
kissing two people find themselves under
the mistletoe they have to audibly
announce to the party a secret about
another person that no one else the
party might know that
turn the dial up to bust up fun turn the
dial up to fun mount a bunch of sticks
of butter in a crock pot or some sort of
saucepan ladle it out to everyone with
cinnamon on top and let them think that
that sec knock no one she knows what
eggnog is but everyone loves thinking
they do there you go I hope that these
last-minute tips on how to handle your
family or friends over the holidays are
helpful and I hope you have a wonderful
safe happy holidays or don't the choice
is yours I guess I don't know thank you
guys for watching this video don't
forget if you like it to hit like and if
you like it more than hitting just like
hit subscribe because I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday and I only
have a couple videos left until the end
of 2014 and they might get a little
sentimental I'm just going to say I'm
feeling really hormonal right now so